let us take a moment to reflect
on what life was like
when it was but you know before the spa
before the single page application
when we had things like MVC and asp.net
web forms on the.net side
of course you know lots and lots of ways
to develop websites
but in a traditional
HTTP rest request response type
application
there is no state there's no way that
you unless you want to store cookies or
have some way to do it on the server
side like the session object
um
everybody's favorite the session object
in asp.net web forms
uh it's sort of um you know you know
it's uh putting round pegs into square
holes or Square pegs and round holes or
something like that the things don't fit
right but with the spa it's a little bit
easier if you've done any react or view
or or angular even knockout
um you know a single page application
there's places where you can you can
stuff stuff
so let's talk about that in Blazer
that's what I'm here to talk about the
ways that you can manage state so first
of all what is State what is in state to
me application state is the things that
are sort of transitory that are in
memory that you need to access from
different components that may or may not
be in scope
right
um the canonical idea that comes to mind
is filling out a form
now I don't know if you've ever had this
uh wonderful experience but in the
states I remember I was filling out a
form for the bank it may have been a
credit card application or application
for some Finance thing or whatever but
they really want like this multiple page
form filled out right
and so you know I get all the easy stuff
you know your name your address and your
this and that and then you get to this
page that's like
you know
um was your mortgage payment a b or c on
this particular date
so I'm like how the hell should I know
right so I gotta get up and I gotta go
to the file cabinet and I gotta pull
stuff out by the time I get back oh I'm
sorry
you've timed out your session has
expired you have to start all over again
right what an infuriating experience
that is right so session state or I'm
sorry application state in that case
will be everything that I've filled into
the form up to that point so when I
reload my session everything is there
that I've already done and you know I've
also had that experience where they did
that for you and it's like whoa
thank you very much but the alternative
is pretty pretty nasty
so I think of when I think of State I
don't think of Secrets I don't think of
anything that needs to go in a database
I think of you know my name my address
my phone number that kind of thing or
just data that I have set to use in the
application that I want to be able to
access from different places it could be
as simple as a switch like a toggle
switch that I turn on in a toolbar or
something like that it tells me I want
to see some features or something like
that right
and it isn't really
isn't really a view model either I mean
we think of when we think of state and
objects that we want to know when
they've changed you know we think of
view models and I notify property change
I actually did a show a Blazer train
show revisiting mvbm
and I asked people like Steve Sanderson
and Chris Sainte and
um
Tim Corey and a couple other people
people I really respect in the business
what do you think about mvvm with blazer
Jeff Fritz from Microsoft was never and
they're all like
yeah you don't really need it you know
Steve Sanderson didn't say that he said
he's very diplomatic he said well we
made Blazer to be sort of agnostic to
whatever patterns you want to use uh we
tried to make it as simple as possible
so you wouldn't have to you know put
stuff on top of it but if you want to go
ahead
yeah he's Steve Sanderson he's
diplomatic he has to say that but
everybody else was like you don't need
mpvm you know
what you need is to be able to have
some properties
or you know an object that has
properties
where they're accessible from all the
different components and all the
different pages in The Spa and they're
taken out of the page itself so just a
little recap about what Blazer is it is
a single page application there is only
one page even though that when you
navigate to different pages you can see
up here at the top the the URL changes
but that's a route within the same
application you're not going and getting
a whole new set of HTML and replacing it
in the browser right it is a spa it's a
single page application but the problem
is and you can see this right here and
I'm sorry to use the counter you know
it's there it's everybody's sick of the
counter but you can see if I increment
the counter
and I move off the page and I go back
it's it's zero again and that's because
every time you go to a page or a
component uh and you navigate away from
that page
and you come back it re initializes and
any page level variables that are in
there get wiped out get re reset
so let me show you what that looks like
and here's Blazer Train by the way
um
if you haven't seen this resource in
your Blazer developer you really should
um if I sort the videos descending the
last one was episode 77 revisiting mvdm
so yeah there's quite a lot of stuff in
here that you can use
um but if we go back to the application
here
and we go to the counter page
you can see that this variable right
there current count is just a page level
variable and that's why it gets
destroyed and reinitialized every time
that page gets navigated to
so let's we can use this as an example
but of state but also add a few more
things so I'm going to show you three
demos here today the first one we're
going to do application State using a
cascading value
if you don't know what that is you will
soon
second we're going to use a service that
we can create a class and add it as a
scoped service so that there's one
instance per user
and we're going to do that because we
might need to to handle an event when
the state changes because we're doing
something other than refreshing the UI
and the third is to take that App State
and persist it to local storage
so that if you're filling out a form for
example and you your session times out
or you come back later at a certain time
you give it a timeout window your data
will come back to life
so let's start with the cascading value
so I have a just a simple Blazer server
application here
and all my code and my toolbox is
missing that's awesome
wow how did that happen
you guys find this happens occasionally
like your your toolbox data goes away
and then it comes back and then it goes
away
okay
shift that's what we're gonna do
I'm going to download
from Blazer train actually I don't need
to download it I have
I have the code here
so yeah I had all these uh things in my
toolbar that um
that I could uh
just
code Snippets
and they're gone so we're just going to
do this the easy way
we're going to pull up the application
app
already already done
so
the cascading parameter type is a is a
cascading value it's a
um
how should we call it a
a component that you wrap around the
entire router the entire app and then
you can initialize that or you can
access it in any page or other component
just by adding a cascading parameter
so
um in my shared project here's my
cascading App State now this is Blazer
server but it would work just as well on
Blazer web assembly right there's no
there's no difference
so here's a pair a pattern you might see
when you want to have a component that
wraps content that wraps markup
you have a cascading value for this
component and you have a render fragment
I call it child content and it's a
parameter
and that child content goes inside this
cascading value
now on this component
I've got some properties I've got a
counter property
and the only difference between this and
a regular get a regular Setter is that
when I set the value I call state has
changed and state has changed is
something that you call to tell Blazer
that hey
something needs to this page needs to be
re-rendered or this component needs to
be re-rendered it's actually at a
component level
and so anything inside the child content
will be re-rendered
okay
message is just a string
and we call state has changed again when
we set the value and the same with this
Boolean property enabled
okay so now if I go to appraiser
I can wrap my entire appraiser the
router which is this is what was there
beforehand in this cascading App State
param component
all right and now I can let's create a
toolbar component
which I've added to the shared folder
and this has a cascading parameter not
just a parameter but a cascading
parameter
called cascading App State
and I call the name of it is App State
but this basically says Okay I want an I
want to have a reference to that
instance and there's only one instance
per user
okay
so here I just have some markup and I'm
looking at App State enabled and I'm
showing a button with that's going to be
green
that says enabled if it's enabled and
otherwise I'm showing a button that says
disabled that's going to be red
now I've also got another button
called update message and when I call
that
when I click that it calls this update
message button clicked which sets App
State message now I don't have to do any
notify property changed or anything like
that
I just set the message because in the
setter I'm calling status changed
wherever it is
message updated at
the current date time
uh then if we go to main layout
instead of the regular about box that I
have normally across the top I'm showing
the toolbar right there
that's the only difference there
and now let's go to the main page
the index page
and look at that
and I've also got my app State reference
here
so remember this is a reference to the
same instance there's only one instance
per user right
so here's my app State and I'm I have a
button to toggle enabled
which basically sets it to the opposite
of what it is and another one to set the
message
so now I can set the message in the
toolbar which is always visible no
matter what the page is
and I have a button to change the
message in the main page as well
so let's check it out
all right so here's my enabled toggle
you can see that this button right here
is changing
if I update the message
I can do that from the page
and I can also update it
from the toolbar in the toolbar no
matter where I am
I can update it and show it right if I
go back to the home page the message
should say 10 34 31.
and it does
now I also have this child component
and just to show you that we can go down
a level
I created a child component also
exposing App State and we're setting the
message from there as well so this is a
child component that's going to be on
the main page
now we're not displaying it but we could
we certainly could we just have a we're
setting the message to message updated
by child component
so boom there you go
so now we've got a page a child
component and another component up at
the top the toolbar that are all
accessing the state
and I also had Rewritten the counter
page so instead of the counter being a
local variable it's App State counter
and here's the the value of that
such as it is I could set the counter
here like six or seven I can go to
another page and come back and it's
still there
and the code for that is just what you'd
expect
yeah I'm
I've got another app State instance not
instance but reference in there
okay so this is where I would start
with App State I would start with a
cascading value and the the Restriction
is or or the the use case is the only
thing I need to do is update the UI
okay if all you need to do is make sure
that this component can update the UI or
read the value of something right
great but what if I want to act on
uh you know when another component
that's not me changes the state
okay now you need to have an event
handler
and it's not that simple
because let's say we Implement an event
handler in this cascading App State
right so we have to have a dispose
method right because we have to unhook
it when we're done
and how do we know who mutated the state
how do I know if it wasn't me
right I so let's say that you want to do
something like um you know write to a
law or something like that in the
toolbar when the state changes
all right so you hook the event but what
if the toolbar was the one that changed
the state
do you know what I'm saying so so you
have to think about not getting into a
quagmire with your code and so there's
another way that we can do this and
that's with the scope service
so let's open that
demo any questions on this one while I'm
opening the new one
no no it just re-renders the component
that you're when you call state has
changed it's within that component
yeah
so let's look at this guy we've got
uh in a Services folder we've got a
class called App State
so app state has a message property an
enabled property and a counter property
and I've got private Setters on here
because I want to control
how these things get set I don't want to
Simply have a public setter
because I need to know who mutated the
state
if it wasn't me great I can take some
action
right it's just a little extra bonus
that I put into this architecture
so I've got a notify State changed
method
that takes a component base or a
component so you could use this
from uh inside a component or a page and
then the property name
and then I'm calling this invoking this
event State changed if it's not if it's
not no in other words if if somebody is
handling it I want to invoke it
um passing the source in the property so
here's my event
it's an action of component base and
string State changed
so now I have
some public methods for updating those
values rather than just being able to
say you know message equals or enabled
equals or counter equals
so I have update message update enabled
update counter so they're able to do the
sets because it's the setter is private
and then we're going to call notify
State changed
so we still have this toolbar
right
but the toolbar is going to inject the
App State and before you can inject
and this is an older demo
so we're using the startup
in configure Services you add a scoped
service
and a scope service is different from a
Singleton in that you get one instance
per user
us if you add Singleton like weather
forecast service you're sharing one
instance with all users
okay
it and this is in Blazer server Blazer
web assembly there's no difference
because there's only one user
right
so we're adding App State as a scoped
service
we're injecting it into the toolbar
we're implementing eye disposable
because down in on initialized we're
handling State changed
with uh this guy right here app state
state changed
and we're in dispose we're unhooking it
with minus equals but you can see right
here if source is not this
than somebody else mutated the state it
wasn't the toolbar
and then I can take I right here all I'm
doing is calling state has changed but
you get an event right you can do
something that's non-ui related
like a log or you know something else
follow so that's why this is a
completely different model from the
cascading parameter if you're wanting to
use a cascading parameter or cascading
value
the only thing you can really do is you
know update right or whatever you can do
in that setter
right but do you really want to do
anything in that setter
well that's up to you
so if a component needs to know when the
state has changed then who changed it
this is a good model
um likewise in the index page
we're doing the same thing we're
injecting App State implementing
disposable
same code as before with a child
component
and instead of saying enabled equals
we're saying apps they update and equal
update enabled this passing this and App
State enabled
not App State enabled same with the
message
so we create a message
we call App State update message passing
this and the message
and
counter
the same way
right injecting the App State disposable
update counter
there you go and the child component
the child component doesn't need to know
in anything is changed because we're
only setting the value but we're setting
it with the update message
yes
25 things magic software investigations
sure yeah the question is can we see
that App State again
um
here it is sorry about that uh yes so
here it is
so update message
sets
met the message property which has a
private setter
and then calls notify State changed so
anybody who's hooking that event can see
it
okay so this should work exactly as it
did before
right the only difference is now
we could actually in let's say toolbar
put a break point here
and if the say child component of the
page updates it you know let me make
this better if if if I update it
everything gets ignored but if the page
updates it
now I get control now I can do something
in the toolbar
yep
and I know that the source is the page I
know you can't see that but it's
application State page Pages dot index
application States the name of my app
questions other questions
yeah so the the main benefit of the
second
um of this of this
scope service is that you can get
control and you can have an event
handler in another component
that's that's the main it's not really
about updating the rendering
um I'm doing a a I'm doing this because
it has to be done anyway you know and uh
so but it's not it's not about that it's
really about
getting control when something changes
which you don't get with the cascading
parameter
other questions
okay
Let's uh try this this other one here
yes
yeah that's a good good question can you
have more than one app State class yes
of course
um
I
I was of the mind and I still am that
you know you can
put everything in one state bag if
you're just going to have a single App
State but if you've got like
a whole bunch of
things that do different things you
might want to break them down by task
right which is sort of the Redux way of
doing things in that you uh you have
every every task that you want to do has
a state it gets more complicated but you
know you certainly have the the ability
to do that if you want it's just a
service you know it's just a scope
service so you can have one for every
different task that you want to do it's
just more work because now you have to
implement it where you want and not
where you don't want yeah
great question though all right so let's
talk about persisting App State
so this is that example that I was
telling you about where you're filling
out a form and you know
you you run out of time and your session
expires and
you have to do the whole thing over
again
how horrible
and it truly is
so for this demo I'm using a tool
that uh Chris Santi wrote and Chris is
here in at NDC and he he's doing a talk
or he did a talk uh he's written a lot
of tools he's written a lot of great
components open source components for
Blazer and one of them is local storage
blazered local storage
right here Blazer local storage
and uh it's a nuget package there's you
just Google it you'll find it and what
I'm doing with this is I'm using it to
store to serialize the state and to
store it
um in local storage now local storage
you get five megabytes per URL per user
right so that's all you get
so it's not like you're gonna stuff you
know
thousand records in there you know
that's not what it's for right
you get five megabytes
so here I have a little bit of a
different architecture I still have a
cascading value but this time the
cascading value has an app State
Property so I have both
in one
and the reason I have both in one is I
don't want to serialize the cascading
App State provider I just want to
serialize App State now
I wrote this in net
5 when
uh the the state of system text Json was
such that you couldn't
serialize uh properties with private
setters
and you could do it with newtonsoft Json
so this is and you can still do Newton
soft Json
so this is what you have to do
you have a private Setter on a property
you have to set it as a Json property
which means it will be serialized even
though it has a private setter
so that's why I'm using Newton soft Json
but check this out so app state has the
message the enabled the counter
but it also has a time to live in
seconds so this is our timeout for
storing the App State in local storage
and I just have it set to 60 seconds to
demonstrate to be able to demonstrate up
here that if I wait 60 seconds which is
easy to do on stage during a demo it
will no longer be available but for in
the real world you're probably going to
want that to live for what a day two
days two hours I don't know that's up to
you
uh and then a date time for last access
because I want to compare that obviously
to the time to live in seconds how much
time has elapsed since I last accessed
this
now the rest of this update message
update enabled update counter and notify
State it's all the same as in the
service
that we had
so you'll notice that we're not
injecting it as a service because it is
uh hanging off of the cascading App
State provider right
here's my local storage service
and you can see here that I'm calling
wait let me close this calling local
storage service get item as string async
Upstate Json
and then I'm looking to see if it's not
null and again this is this is older
code so it's not as efficient as it
could be today
I'm deserializing the object and then
I'm looking at last accessed
checking the date time and if it is
within the window I'm setting App State
to that object otherwise I'm
instantiating a new app state
now I have a save changes that's
synchronous and one that's asynchronous
we're setting last accessed is now
serializing the object and then storing
that
in local storage
and just in case you need a link to
something that shows you how much local
storage you have and guess what it's
five megabytes here's the link
uh again the appraiser we put the
cascading App State provider around it
and
you know our our toolbar looks very much
the same
right except that when state has changed
we're going to save it
right here in the toolbar this is the
only place we're going to save it
even though we're accessing it in the
index page
we're not going to save it there
right we're just going to invoke status
changed
so let's do this demo
value cannot be no
yes
is there a reason why why I wouldn't
want to have the save in
of the state itself oh yeah because you
can't you can't deserialize yourself and
replace yourself
that's why
yeah
um maybe I already in what's occurring
to me here is I get this error cannot be
no is that it might be this guy right
here is something that's already
living on my
in my application here so let's just
change that
one more time
that's awesome
that's so awesome all right let's see
here I can figure this out
just run it one more time
foreign
tool called debugging
break point
I'm going to put one right there
and by the way
oh yeah okay so this is actually a
webassembly application that's why
that's what's going on here
and I might not actually get that break
point because it's a webassembly
application
value cannot be null parameter input
yeah this is awesome
it's just great
no I didn't need to do that because it
is a parameter of
um
injected
no we're not in the sorry
um
let me check I didn't think I did I
don't think I had to because it is a
property
oh yeah I'm injecting local storage yeah
that's great
input input
foreign
builds no problem all right let's
see if I can do something else here
John you have a
um a repo I can download that does this
storage right
all right let's try
let's go back the Blazer train and
download it again oh I know what I can
do to get this
show video of it working
yes yes I can
persisting App State
so we're going to go toward the end here
hi I'm Carl Franklin hey Carl Franklin
how are you
let's go toward the end
and
create it
it's exactly it's okay
it's within
what's wrong that's 113 bytes by the way
we can update the message update the
message here
updating the child component just like
we did before now let's close the app
run it again within 60 seconds and there
it is this is exactly the way we left it
so you're gonna have to trust me
and look 90 seconds later
there you go
all right so there's one other thing I
want to bring to your attention
which is new is kind of new to me
because I was never really a Redux uh
person or or
but there's
um
a tool called fluxor
and I have a managing app state with
fluxor which uses the flux pattern but
it's all C sharp and it's all for Blazer
so anybody do Redux
and yeah okay and react so it's that
pattern it's the same flux pattern where
you have a state and you have a manager
and you've got a store and then you have
a dispatcher and you know there's a lot
of stuff and there's a lot of steps in
here
but it does work and it is really cool
and I guess the whole reason that you
would use this
is it the state is immutable so rather
than
uh rather than just changing the state
from from somewhere and then getting you
know knowing who changed it right like I
do you replace the state and you have
the the prescriptive architecture is as
you said to have different State uh
stores for each task that you want to
perform
right so whereas you know you might have
one for
um adding something to your shopping
cart that's a completely separate State
bag if you will and it's completely
separate store because it only deals
with those things
if you want something that is shared
among you know a task where different
components have to know when that state
changes then those guys can
can handle the state in in there without
fear of
stepping on uh each other
um I don't know I'm not convinced that
this is a really good way to go it's a
bit complex and you know my my colleague
uh Dom wiebea from Dev expresses also
feels the same
that it is cool but it's a lot it's a
lot of stuff there so I would start with
the cascading option and if you need to
get control Beyond
um you know if you need to hook an event
when somebody else mutates the state
then you could use the uh the service
the scope service if you want to persist
it you can use both you can have the app
State service hanging as a property off
of your app State provider which you can
then use to serialize and deserialize
that and store it somewhere it doesn't
have to be local storage either
it could be you know in a database it
could be in a cookie I guess if you
really want to it could be in a sqlite
database you know
so that that is pretty much it I mean if
you have any other questions I'll be
happy to take them now
yeah which is better indexeddb or sqlite
um indexeddb has been classically the
way people go but sqlite is kind of like
the new hotness with blazer
um I don't know does anybody else have
an opinion on that I haven't used either
really so with blazer
anyone
yeah
yeah I I think if you're getting more
than five megabytes of State
you might want to reconsider
what's going in there but I have no idea
what your application is so I don't know
yeah you might want to use a database on
the server side instead
anybody else
questions
I have a question how come I can't get
heavy cream
in London anywhere
double cream yeah how come I can't get
that
yeah I know but the Barista is like the
coffee places they're like
why would you want that
never all right well that's my talk
you're getting out a little early thanks